tonight one of these three nominees will  be added to the distinguished list of  Oscar winners Gregg the nominees are  from Baghdad cafe  calling you music and lyric by Bob  Chelsea from working girl let the river  run music and lyric by Carly Simon from  Buster two hearts  music by Lamont Dozier lyric by Phil  Collins and the Oscar goes to Carly  Simon for let the river run from working  though  so much thank you  listen this is really for you Mike you  you are the guardian angel tonight thank  you so much and thank you to my husband  Jim Hart for writing the best lines in  the song thank you sweetheart  and to 20th Century Fox and to Clive  Davis and everyone at Arista and to rob  mounds II who made the song sound good  and my children if you found a  television set and on that island where  you are your mom is really proud  please welcome miss Candice Bergen  analyst Jacqueline Bisset